do you use Twitter Facebook YouTube
Instagram or snapchat to keep up with
the world 68 percent of Americans get at
least some of their news through social
media and for the under 30 set that
figures a lot higher the tech giant's
are private companies and for the most
part have the freedom to determine
what's posted on their platforms but are
there choices about what content to
remove and who to evict really being
made free from government pressures it's
not enough to just give people a voice
we need to make sure that people aren't
using it to harm other people or to
spread misinformation can you define
hate speech senator I think that this is
a really hard question we should be
particularly worried about asking
platforms to take things down if they're
over in this realm where it's very hard
to tell what's illegal and where what
you're taking down might be important
public political speech
Daphne Keller is a former Google
attorney who's currently a law professor
at Stanford she says that the tech
giants are facing pressure from
governments worldwide to clamp down on a
variety of content on their platform
from terrorist propaganda to
disinformation to hate speech the
European Union is currently debating new
so-called terrorist content regulations
which would mandate the tech giant's
prohibit so-called violent or extremist
speech and propaganda on their platforms
Keller says the worst versions would
empower police to inform tech companies
when they see posts violating the Terms
of Service social media users agree to
when first signing up the European
Commission has looked to Terms of
Service as a means of getting platforms
to take down content without going
through the process of passing a new law
or a regulation the hate speech code of
conduct was negotiated between Microsoft
YouTube Facebook Twitter and the
European Commission and that commits
those platforms to using their Terms of
Service to prohibit hate speech under a
definition that's derived from European
law but because they're using their
Terms of Service to do it that means
that the prohibition is global so are we
in a sense living
under European Union internet regulation
right now in America to a certain extent
things that would be politically
difficult and perhaps unconstitutional
or in some cases certainly
unconstitutional to mandate here we
don't have to even consider because they
get mandated in Europe and then
companies apply them globally Twitter
CEO Jack Dorsey says that his company
follows a speech code developed by the
United Nations wasn't the UN declaration
guarantee the right of all people
through any medium to express their
opinion it does and why it also has it
also has can it also has conditions
around particular speech inciting
violence and some of the some of the
aspects that we speak to as well and it
protectors of certain categories whether
it's religion race gender sexual
orientation those are all also protected
under the UN covenant article 20 of the
United Nations Covenant on Civil and
Political Rights that dorcy references
says that so-called hate speech which it
defines as any advocacy of national
racial or religious hatred that
constitutes incitement to discrimination
hostility or violence shall be
prohibited by law the First Amendment by
contrast prevents the US government from
regulating speech based on content
people might be airing legitimate
grievances about something their
government is doing or something that a
foreign government is doing they might
be engaging in conversation that is very
important in their political context if
that gets mistaken for terrorism by a
sort of trigger-happy employee sitting
in California
that's going to disrupt really core
political speech Keller calls this
effect collateral censorship and says
we've seen it on the internet before
when strict copyright enforcement led to
unnecessary takedowns we've found that
there are a lot of bad faith notices you
get things like the government of
Ecuador using a nonsense copyright claim
to get journalistic criticism taken down
the Church of Scientology used some
spurious copyright accusations to get
criticism taken down and there's
research showing that some platforms
just don't even bother to try to
which allegations are true and which
allegations are false they just honor
all of them I am optimistic that over a
five to ten year period we will have AI
tools that can get into some of the
nuances the linguistic nuances of
different types of content to be more
accurate and flagging things for our
systems does that solve the problem no
okay I does not of the brother everybody
who claims that there are filters or AI
or machine learning that can solve these
problems has something to sell the
public has very little information about
how well any of it is working there are
two major studies I'm aware of about the
efficacy of filters in identifying
unlawful content and both of them casts
serious doubt one study out of Reggie
University Amsterdam found that AI
designed to catch hate speech on Twitter
misclassified at 80 percent of the time
another joint study out of China and the
UK found that hate speech lacks unique
discriminative features and is difficult
to discover and after Europe reached an
agreement with the tech companies to
build a terrorism hash database that
used a AI to automatically flag and
remove extremist propaganda YouTube took
down an entire archive meant to document
war crimes in Syria these lawmakers and
policy makers are motivated by wanting
to stop the spread of terrorism wanting
to stop what's become known as self
radicalization what's the big deal that
a few things get taken down accidentally
if we're stopping people from joining
Isis right now we don't have any clear
information telling us that taking down
all of these videos really is making us
safer in fact a lot of people who are
expert researchers on security are
concerned that this will effectively
drive more people into darker corners of
the internet into echo chambers where
they only ever hear from people who
agree with a violent agenda there are
people in law enforcement who would
prefer sometimes to leave things up so
that they can monitor what's going on
and go after the the perpetrators of
real-world violence so it's not clear
what the security upside is at the same
time it's not entirely clear what the
speech and expression down side is we
know there's a downside we know those
hundred thousand videos from the Syrian
archive that were documenting violence
in Syria for future prosecution
disappeared we know there's harm to
speech but we can't quantify that either
because we don't have the data and
transparency from platforms or from
governments to understand that side of
the calculation back in the u.s.
Democratic presidential candidate
Elizabeth Warren has publicly called for
the breakup of the tech giants and the
Federal Trade Commission and Justice
Department are gearing up for antitrust
investigations into Facebook and Google
and conservatives like Republican
senators Josh Hawley and Ted Cruz have
called for social media companies to be
treated more like public utilities that
have to treat all content as neutral or
lose their liability protection right
now big tech enjoys an immunity from
liability on the assumption that they
would be neutral and fair if they're not
going to be neutral and fair if they're
gonna be biased we should repeal the
immunity from liability so they should
be liable like the rest of us I don't
even know what being neutral would mean
would it mean allowing every single
thing to be uploaded and just showing it
in chronological order can you be
neutral if you have search features can
you be neutral if you allow people to
mute things a truly neutral meaning
showing everything that is legal social
media platform would be full of content
that most users don't want to see and
that certainly advertisers don't want to
have next to their ads Keller says that
the best way to reduce the power of
Google Facebook and Twitter is through
new competition which regulation can
stifle so when Mark Zuckerberg requests
a more active role for governments in
monitoring his own company perhaps his
underlying motive is to protect Facebook
from competition by raising the barriers
to entry there does seem to be the sense
that Twitter and Facebook are
controlling the conversation in a way at
this point the public conversation do
you think that is going to continue to
be the case going forward or are we on
the verge of something different if
we're on the verge of something
different I don't know what it is and I
think if we continue seeing laws passed
that more or less entrench incumbents by
making requirements that only they can
afford to comply with that makes it much
less likely that we ever get to this
other future where we get away from the
the current information gatekeepers
having the role that they do now
[Music]